[Music]
I have not made an apple store video in
a really long time probably needs two
drops it's worth day actually so I
thought I need to make one I'm waiting
for Taryn
I don't know where she is we're going to
see Star Trek really excited although
I'm actually not really a big Star Trek
fan I always remember it used to come on
like the only station that we would get
when I was interviewed on cable click it
and watch something else but that's
beside the point
excited to see you because I tweeted
earlier and everybody said that it was
really really good so I'm gonna watch it
and enjoy it leave a comment below it
seems car traffic and if you like but
don't get weak and spoilers because I
haven't seen it yet actually probably
you're coming so feel free to spoil it
okay stop stop